S
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S ABILITY TO
RESCUE HIS REELING PARTY.
ONE DNC COMMITTEE MEMBER TOLD
THE TIMES "TO SAY OUR COUNTRIES
ON THE RIGHT TRACK WOULD
FLAGRANTLY DEPART FROM REALITY.
"ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," JOE WAS
LASHING OUT AT HIS OWN STAFF AND
HIS CHIEF OF STAFF RON KLAIN.
BIDEN FREQUENTLY IS BLAMING
FLORIDA SENATOR RICK SCOTT FOR
SOME REASON.
ACCORDING TO JOE, RICK SCOTT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF THE
ECONOMIC WOES.
HE'S ONE SENATOR.
NOT A JOKE AS HE LIKES TO SAY.
NOT A JOKE.
FOR GOD'S SAKES.
SENATOR SCOTT IS RESPONDING IN A
STRONG WAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JOE BIDEN HAS DESTROYED
AMERICA'S ECONOMY.
IT'S TIME TO BE HONEST WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
JOE BIDEN'S UNDER OFFICE SHOULD
RESIGN.
I'M RICK SCOTT FLORIDA, AND I DO
HAVE A PROBLEM AND SO DOES EVERY
AMERICAN.
BIDEN IS FORCING AMERICA INTO
RECESSION.
I'VE A PLAN TO TURN OUR COUNTRY
AROUND.
TAKE A LOOK AT RESCUE
AMERICA.COM.
I APPROVE THIS MESSAGE.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION,
FLORIDA SENATOR RICK SCOTT.
IF I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU TAKE UP
SO MUCH SPACE IN HIS HEAD, BUT
APPARENTLY YOU DO.
APPARENTLY IT'S A COMPLIMENT.
HE REALLY HAS DESTROYED THE
ECONOMY.
41 YEAR HIGH OF INFLATION, YOU
CAN SEE THE NUMBERS.
A DEFINITE RECESSION ON THE
HORIZON ACCORDING TO THE
EXPERTS.
EVEN LAUREN SUMMERS.
IF YOU WANT HIM TO THE RESIGN
BUT WE NEVER -- WE KNOW HE'S
NEVER GOING TO RESIGN.
>> HERE'S THE PROBLEM JOE BIDEN
HAS.
HE'S A RICH KID, NO, HE WENT TO
INEXPENSIVE PREP SCHOOL.
HE'S BEEN ON THE PUBLIC DOLE FOR
50 YEARS.
WE'VE BEEN PAYING HIS WAY FOR 50
YEARS.
HE HAS NO IDEA ABOUT ANYTHING.
HE DOESN'T CARE.
SO, NO PLAN TO FIX ANYTHING.
HE'S CONFUSED, INCAPACITATED,
UNFIT FOR OFFICE.
I'D GO TO JOE AND SAY, NICE GUY,
NICE TRY, YOU'VE GOT TO LEAVE.
YOU CANNOT DO THE JOB.
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE WE WIN IN
NOVEMBER AND WE'VE GOT TO STOP
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FROM
DOING ALL THESE THINGS.
$5 GAS?
GAS IMPACTS.
I GREW UP IN A POOR FAMILY.
MY MOM WOULD BE STRUGGLING LIKE
CRAZY RIGHT NOW TO PUT FOOD ON
THE TABLE AND FEED FIVE KIDS AND
PUT GAS IN THE CARD TO GET TO
WORK.
THAT'S GOING ON ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND MY STATE.
WE'VE GOT TO CHANGE AND WE'VE
GOT TO BECOME ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
WE CAN'T KEEP DOING WHAT BIDEN
IS DOING.
BUT LOOK AT WHO BIDEN PICKS.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA HOW TO DO
ANYTHING.
THEY'VE NEVER DONE ANYTHING.
THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF THEM
OUGHT TO RESIGN AND LET'S START
ALL OVER.
>> Sean: I'M LOOKING AT THE
AMOUNT OF PRESSURE.
LOOK, THE DEFINITION OF INSANITY
IS WHAT I SAID IT IS.
IF YOU TRY THE SAME THING OVER
AND OVER AGAIN AND IT DOESN'T
WORK.
THE QUESTION IS YOU SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE HIGH PRICE OF
GAS, SAID IN ONE RECORD ANOTHER.
HE READS THE PAPER APPEARED AND
SOMEBODY HAS TO BE TELLING HIM
IT'S A 41 YEAR HIGH OF
INFLATION.
THE QUESTION IS WHY IT IS THIS
RELUCTANCE AND RESISTANCE ON THE
PART OF BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT WHY ARE THEY OKAY WITH
IMPORTING OIL RATHER THAN
PRODUCING IT RIGHT HERE AT HOME?
TO ME, MOTHER EARTH IS BETTER
OFF IF WE PRODUCE IT.
>> WHO DOESN'T WANT TO BE
INDEPENDENT?
OUR COUNTRY WE SHOULD BE
INDEPENDENT.
WE SHOULDN'T BE DEPENDENT ON
ANYBODY ELSE FOR ANYTHING, AND
MAY BE OUR BUT NOBODY ELSE.
I THINK IT'S SIMPLE AS THIS.
HE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND THE
ECONOMY AND HE DOESN'T CARE
BECAUSE HE'S NEVER HAD TO.
HE'S NEVER HAD A TOUGH FINANCIAL
DAY IN HIS LIFE AND HE DOESN'T
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE POOR.
HE'S NEVER BEEN POOR.
LOOK AT WHO'S AROUND HIM.
AND THERE'S NOBODY AROUND HIM
THAT'S EVER DONE ANYTHING IN
BUSINESS.
AS A WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT, PEOPLE
THINK GOVERNMENT CAN RUN
ANYTHING.
NO CONCEPT OF HOW TO FIX THE
SUPPLY CHAIN.
>> Sean: YOU'RE IN THE SENATE
AND YOU DEAL WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
I KNOW JOE MANCHIN'S PROBABLY ON
OUR SIDE ON THIS.
IT MAY BE A CHRISTIAN CINEMA I
DON'T KNOW.
ANY OTHER DEMOCRATS LOOKING AT
THE RECORD HIGH PRICES OF
GASOLINE AND INFLATION AND CAN
WE WORK TOGETHER TO GET THE
ECONOMY BACK IN BETTER SHAPE AND
MAY BE THAT INCLUDES RESTARTING
THE KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE?
ACCORDING TO THE -- WE'D BE
GETTING A 900,000 BARRELS OF
CANADIAN OIL AND DAY BY NOW HAD
WE FINISHED THAT.
IS THERE ANYBODY YOU'RE TALKING
TO ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE THAT'S
WILLING TO BREAK RANKS AND GIVE
FINANCIAL RELIEF TO EVERYDAY
AMERICANS?
>> NO.
THEY'LL SAY THEY CARE ABOUT IT,
AND THEY SEE HOW BAD THE POLL
NUMBERS ARE.
THEY WILL SAY THEY CARE ABOUT
THAT, BUT WILL THEY VOTE FOR IT
OR PROPOSE ANYTHING TO DO IT?
THERE'S NOTHING THAT COMES OUT
THAT FIXES ANYTHING IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN, ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, ANY OF THE THINGS.
A BABY FORMULA!
THEY HAVE NO PLAN TO FIX
ANYTHING!
HE'S BEEN OUT AT LONG BEACH ONE
TIME SINCE HE'S BEEN IN OFFICE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO FIX THE
SUPPLY CHAIN?
WELL, NOT MY PROBLEM.
SHE SAYS WHAT ARE YOU DOING
ABOUT INFLATION?
THE FEDERAL RESERVE'S
RESPONSIBILITY.
THEY TAKE NO RESPONSIBILITY AND
IT STARTS WITH BIDEN.
IT TAKES NO RESPONSIBILITY AND
COMPLETE TO BLAME EVERYBODY
ELSE.
HE IS NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR